MARK MOORE: The world in which
each of us, and all of us,
now live is full of pressing
problems and future risks.
But it's also full of hope,
aspiration, and opportunity.
Public leaders can come
in many different guises.
They can be ordinary citizens
who take up a local cause.
They can manage a non-profit
organization or a voluntary association
that provides services to
those in need and security
to those who are oppressed.
They can be individuals who
run for elective office,
hoping to create more economic,
social, or political equality.
They can serve in government,
hoping to increase
the responsiveness,
efficiency, effectiveness,
and fairness of government operations.
In Leadership, Creating
Public Value, you
will learn how to face and meet the
challenge of diagnosing the reality you
confront and designing a
public value proposition that
is both plausibly value-creating
and actionable by you
in your particular context.
Through case studies, you
will see real public leaders
seeking to challenge the status quo.
You'll be asked to reflect
on their thought and action,
using the analytic frameworks and
concepts developed and applied
throughout the course.
The goal is simple.
Learn how to create
long-term public value
by envisioning and enacting a better
and more just future for us all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]